[Musique]
stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir mon souhait merci d'être
avec nous au moment où le gouvernement a
traversé un orage lourd de menaces avec
le monde agricole qui gronde en
arrière-plan hervé hasquin de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire avec
dailymotion et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat nous rejoindront pour
vous interroger mais on attend bien sûr
tout de suite monsieur le foll vos
réponses sur la situation en bretagne
vous serez donc à rennes vendredi pour
préciser l'aide qui sera apportée au
secteur de l'agroalimentaire ce que vous
mettez un préalable à votre déplacement
par exemple la fin des manifestations
diverses ou des destructions de
portiques et autres bornes de l'écotaxe
moi j'estime que
le sujet est pour les salariés
suffisamment grave pour qu'on puisse
avoir un dialogue franc et sincère sur
les solutions
je ne pense pas que il soit nécessaire
pour ça d'avoir a constaté des actes de
violence donc je pense au contraire
qu'il faut que maintenant
non je le disais la sincérité de
l'engagement de chacun la responsabilité
de chacun on puisse travailler à trouver
des solutions
réalisables à votre déplacement qui est
très attendu et notamment vous êtes
attendus même on peut dire de pied ferme
par les salariés et les patrons qui sont
unis du secteur de la filière de la
volaille par exemple et vous avez promis
à ceux de tissa co2 relancée à bruxelles
la question des subventions quand été
supprimée de longue date mais là je vais
les récits ont pris alors chez huit noms
mais je vais pas si j'ai envoyé un mot
hier soir pdg de ti lyssach ou qui m'a
demandé si j'acceptais est la condition
de la contrepartie cité qu'il y avait
une v2 de l'occupation de la sous
préfecture et sur la facture s'accepter
de d'emmener avec moi devant le
commissaire une délégation des
entreprises qui bénéficiaient jusqu'ici
jusqu'à 2000 jusqu'en juillet ils
trichent l'été dernier des restitutions
à l'exportation pour rencontrer le
commissaire j'ai donc répondu de manière
très claire oui je l'accepté et je ne
vais pas me mettre dans une situation où
j'aurais refusé une demande qui consiste
à dire on veut aller à bruxelles pour
discuter aujourd'hui des conditions dans
lesquelles on se trouve et voir avec la
commission ce que l'on peut faire
j'étais au delà a bien sûr non mais moi
je je suis prêt votre votre pari c'est
quoi alors là on vous a compris on vous
envoie entendu il va essayer d'établir
d'obtenir le rétablissement des
subventions d'abord je n'ai pas jamais
dit ça et j'ai dit que j'acceptais la
proposition qui m'a été faite alors cédé
tellement vrai c'est tellement vrai que
j'ai pris et nous avons pris des
contacts avec la commission européenne
que le porte-parole de dacian ciolos
vient d'annoncer que le commissaire
était prêt à recevoir une délégation
avec le ministre donc là on est vrai que
il a rappelé d'ailleurs les rays qui
était la question des restitutions et il
a dit en même temps qu'on était prêt à
discuter pour avoir aussi les
possibilités qui sont ouverts par
l'europe sur un certain nombre d'êtres
qui pourraient être mobilisés voilà ce
qui est dit par le halal kalliste me
laisser terminer s'il vous plaît parce
que je veux pas te derrière on
interprète les choses mal il ya un
communiqué du porte parole du
commissaire européen qui est disponible
et qui précise un certain nombre de
choses et qui dit en même temps qu'on
est prêts à discuter d'un certain nombre
de sujets en particulier sur des
mobilisations des aides possibles à
l'investissement ou à des z sur des
questions liées à oui je disais
l'investissement d'autres peut-être même
de trésorerie faut qu'on regarde ça mais
je n'ai jamais dit et hier soir quand
j'ai répondu à la demande qui m'a été
fait c'est pas pour dire oui je suis là
pour dire ça y est on va remettre en
place des restitutions je vous dire une
chose
d'abord de manière très claire pour que
tout le monde comprenne tous ceux qui
regardent sur les restitutions au
phalère et structures qui est les
subventions région à l'export et à
l'exportation
en 2005 l'europe décide de les supprimer
j'étais tout à l'heure à une audition au
sénat michel barnier a rappelé en 2008
qu'elle allait s'arrêter série l'édition
2008 entre 2005 et aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui a été fait parce qu'ils avaient des
responsabilités gouvernementales ou
parce qu'ils avaient des responsabilités
à la tête des anglais industriels les
industriels rien on est donc aujourd'hui
dans cette situation et je vais rappeler
ce que j'ai fait parce que moi j'assume
mes responsabilités
quand je suis arrivé tout les
restitutions toutes ces subventions à
l'exportation ont été supprimés entre
avril 2012 et septembre 2012 toute
viande bovine viande porcine viande
ovine the lady porcine va coeur et
bovine est interdite d'accord toutes ont
été supprimés entre avril 2012 avant que
nous arrivions et septembre 2012 seuls
les restitutions à l'exportation pour
les volailles ont été maintenus et elles
ont été maintenues un an entre l'été
2012 et l'été 2013 parce que je les
demande et parce que contrairement à ce
qui a été dit hier soir par certains je
me suis battu pour maintenir des
restitutions parce que je savais les
difficultés de cette lumière en
particulier quand je suis arrivé en mai
2012 et bien la société d'où étaient
déjà en redressement judiciaire donc il
faut qu'on soit clair et bien vous
l'êtes mais il faut être clair encore
plus précisément peut-être est ce mono
dit là ce soir il n'est pas question de
rétablir ces subventions qui ont été
supprimées de longue date on est de
rappeler le calendrier est effectivement
nous avons fait en tant qu'etat un
recours devant la cour de justice quand
la commission a pris sa décision on a eu
une discussion avec la commission je
voulais pas que cette décision soit
prise j'ai proposé au commissaire pour
puces les prolonger il m'a dit que ce
n'était pas possible puisque l'huile
dans sa position ça faisait un an qu'il
avait supprimé toutes les autres nous
avons donc essayé en commission dans le
cadre d'un cessna conseils liés à
l'agriculture de mobiliser une minorité
de blocage des états contre cette
décision nous n'avons pas pu avoir la
minorité de blocage ensuite puisque vous
n'avez pas la capacité politique de
contrer cette décision de la commission
nous sommes nous avons déposé un recours
devant la cour de justice en arguant le
fait que ces restitutions était là pour
compenser les variations de monnaie et
que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le real a
baissé de manière à la monnaie de
résilier effectivement la mode et
brésilienne a baissé donc nous ailleurs
contesté ces décisions voilà tout ce
qu'on a fait en responsabilité mais
total certains d'entre vous ont mal
compris vous l'avez dit vous-même et
même certains membres de votre majorité
présidentielle puisque j'entends
l'écologiste barbara pompili qui est
quand même la vice-présidente du groupe
à l'assemblée nationale dire que vous
êtes peut-être céder trop vite à
l'occupation de la sous-préfecture de
morlaix non mais là je voudrais quand
même qu'on soit là aussi moi je pense
aux salariés il y avait des salariés qui
sont dans le doute et dans le désespoir
j'ai parfaitement compris il était dans
la cour de la préfecture après avoir
d'ailleurs cassé là le portique de la
préfecture et la discussion qui s'est
engagé avec le pdg de ti lyssach au
c'était de me demander si j'acceptais de
pouvoir conduire une délégation à
bruxelles pour discuter de ces questions
liées à la fin des restitutions et aux
problèmes rencontrés par cette filière
je ne me voyais pas moi refuser cette
possibilité puisque dans le dialogue que
nous avons eues il y avait derrière le
fait que l'ensemble des salariés qui
étaient dans cette pour quitter la cour
d'eau que j'ai accepté cette discussion
de ces gars là sion à ce que vous aurez
toute la filière de la volaille derrière
vous et ce soir vous nous dites
l'objectif c'est d'obtenir des aides et
subventions j'utilisais une discuter et
la collection donnera les raisons pour
laquelle elle a pris cette décision
si moi quand je me suis quand j'ai
discuté que le commissaire gêne pas pu
obtenir le maintien même si mois de plus
patrick il ya des raisons et en même
temps ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
comprendre la commission c'est ce que
j'avais dit à l'époque pour essayer
encore de maintenir six mois de plus ces
restitutions alors qu'ils avaient
maintenu pendant un an c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on peur ensemble faire pour soutenir
cette filière parce que je le dis aussi
cette filière que ce soit 12 août elissa
qu on a un marché à l'exportation qui
existe depuis 40 ans et il y a un
potentiel sur lequel il faut qu'on
s'appuie moi je suis là pour dire aux
salariés aux éleveurs que mon projet
c'est de maintenir une filière
exportatrice de poulet sur le grand
monocoque est ce que vous diriez que
beaucoup d'années ont été perdus que
vous avez rappelé encore une fois le
calendrier vous avez dit que les
industriels n'ont pas su s'adapter ces
millions de l'europe ont été gâchées
d'une certaine manière pour ces patients
6 60 millions oui non mais c'était une
restitution qui te est élevé oui moi je
fais pas alors maintenant je vais pas
faire ils ont endormi les industries je
ne sais pas assez d'aisance dormir je
constate une chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui
alors que tout le monde savait tout le
monde savait et les responsables en
particulier et je le disais tout à
l'heure je n'ai entendu dans la
commission du sénat auquel je participe
et que c'est que restitution allait
disparaître et je constate que arrivant
aux responsabilités on a eu le problème
de doux j'ai tout fait pour les
maintenir et je les ai maintenu pendant
un an un accord mais que pendant toute
la période qui est passé personne n'a
tenu compte du fait qu'on allait finir
par ne plus avoir de ces restitutions de
subventions à l'exportation jouer avec
la gueule de bois est ce que vous diriez
que cette période une ses
responsabilités est ce que cette période
marque la fin de l'agriculture
productiviste en bretagne ans et
certains me disent ça c'est facile de
considérer que c'est la fin de la vie
future productivité alors c'est quoi le
début de l' autre agriculture je
rappelle d'abord que il ya un marché sur
le moyen-orient qui existent ça fait 40
ans que des pulls et sont produits en
france et sont exportés sur ce marché en
arabie soudite dans l'ensemble du
moyen-orient et donc ça c'est une ça
existe on est concurrencés par qui par
les producteurs brésiliens on peut dire
après tout eh bien on n'a pas besoin de
produire du tout liées à l'exportation
on va laisser les brésiliens première
hypothèse c'est pas la mienne je
considère que la france et la bretagne a
une vocation avec présentes sur ce
marché deuxième hypothèse on peut
considérer de dire eh bien il suffit de
faire du blé de qualité ya déjà un
marché sous le pôle de qualité nous
sommes le grand pays européen qui a ce
qu'on appelle des labels agriculteurs à
venir vous mettrez je finis ya des
productions de la belle elles sont
importantes et la france est le seul
grand pays européen qui et qui à ce type
de production mais en même temps il ya
du poulet standard aussi parce que on
est arrivé au bout de la demande des
poulets de qualité donc il faut qu'on
soit capable de s'adapter de rester
aussi avec des objectifs sanitaires et
de qualité élevée mais en même temps de
ne pas se priver de débouchés qui
existent donc c'est pas la fin d'un
modèle c'est son évolution alors vous
allez donc à rennes vendredi nonobstant
les manifestations et encore ces
portiques que l'on démonte que l'ont
enflammé ce que le ministre de
l'intérieur est à la hauteur de la
situation est ce que c'est à chaque fois
l'autorité de l'état qui est bafouée sur
les routes de francs on est dans un
moment où j'ai vu encore hier soir les
salariés les éleveurs tout le monde est
dans le doute il ya une logique où une
crispation une vraie difficulté à
accepter
quoi que ce soit aujourd'hui donc il
faut qu'on soit capable aussi d'être à
l'écouté d'être gelée dire intelligent
d'avoir ce sens minimes hommes
politiques et déporté quand les démente
qui consiste à ne pas chercher à
provoquer à chercher au contraire à ne
pas laisser penser que quelqu'un peut
avoir une victoire dans ce débat la
seule victoire qu'il faut qu'on ait
s'est trouvé les solutions pour s'en
sortir
pour redresser ses filières la grosse
décote alors maintenant sur l'écotaxe et
les portésiens et les portiques vous
savez très bien que sur cette question
il ya un débat qui est en cours un sur
les conditions auxquelles tous indiquent
les forces de l'ordre font leur travail
et manuel valls a salué ce travail et il
a raison c'est à la fois le maintien
c'est à la fois aussi la capacité à être
suffisamment
présent tout en n'étant pas agressif
parce qu'on sait qu'on est sur une
tension c'est comme ça à réinventer
c'est comme ça qu'on gère les choses je
ne sais pas c'est des choses qui se
discute mais c'est pas le ministre de
l'agriculture et qui annonce quoi que ce
soit mais enfin sur ce contrat est ce
que vous diriez que c'est un scandale
d'état moi je ne dirais pas je vais pas
faire de la députée verts pour lui
c'est un député c'est le parlement moi
justement je vais pas me mettre à faire
ce que font certains en particulier
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition qui ont
pas assez c'est sur cette question des
contacts de dire des choses qui sont
complètement en dehors de ce que devrait
être un débat républicain à avoir une
position la défendre j'ai entendu madame
kosciusko morizet a évoqué un état voyou
de quoi on parle
je dis simplement que ce contrat de
partenariat privé public faisait que si
l'état le dj renoncer à ce contrat on
devait 800 millions d'euros à cette
société ecomouv et que dans ce contrat
pour collecter 1 milliards vers 2200
millions d'euros eh bien on avait un
coût de fonctionnement de 250 millions
d'euros c'est à dire autour de 20 à 25%
en coûts de fonctionnement ce qui sur
une collecte d'une taxe est assez
exceptionnel voilà 8 mois vous donnez
combien de temps pour faire entrer en
vigueur cette nouvelle taxe l'écotaxe
combien de temps dans combien de mois
sera en vigueur moi je pense que sur le
débat qui a eu il ya une suspension
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit capable
là aussi de prendre en compte ce qui a
été
évoqué par un certain nombre de
d'acteurs en particulier dans
l'agriculture dans l'agroalimentaire et
surtout aussi considéré que c'était
quotaxe c'est la capacité qu'on a à
financer demain des infrastructures
importantes en particulier niveau
ferroviaire et d'autre et de voir que
des camions puissent traverser la france
en venant d'autres pays sans rien payer
et c'est le budget d'état qui finance
les routes et les autoroutes ça c'est un
vrai sujet révélait alors j'ai pas des
modèles mais parce que ça a été suspendu
par le premier ministre moi je respecte
les temps qui sont souvenus du
gouvernement et du premier ministre qui
aura à mener la discussion je le ferai
avec guillaume garot et frédéric
cuvillier est aussi philippe martin on
va essayer de réfléchir la manière à
coeur dont vois les choses elle arrivait
en route face à cet orage et au danger
d'un soulèvement général parce qu'il ya
le risque de contagion n'avait pas parlé
mais on va y revenir ses fans le fun et
bien comment le gouvernement et le chef
de l'état peut-il réagir sachant que le
chef de l'état affronte une défiance
sans précédent on va en parler dans un
instant avec notre confrère hervé
hasquin de l' agence france-presse juste
après sur une guerre sans concession
porté également par la presse européenne
camilla campus à nouveau
sans idée incompétent son cap la presse
européenne frappent fort sur françois
hollande est ce que le gouvernement a
encore une politique l'air y est ce
qu'est ce que françois hollande a encore
là à la force et le pouvoir nécessaire
pour agir les gouvernements à virer avec
complément à droite aussi dans les juges
et sociale donc ça c'est vraiment à un
renoncement à l'éprît site que c'est
plus pour moi c'est plus inquiétant
l'impréparation et l'improvisation et
espèce de
des autres dont le gouvernement français
des mots durs qui ne sont pas passés
inaperçus ici presseurop c'est un site
d'information qui sélectionne
quotidiennement des articles les
journaux de toute l'europe sont
décortiqués le constat est clair la
presse est unanime et le ton de plus en
plus acides depuis quelques semaines ce
point de vue là est nouveau c'est un
point de vue européen françois hollande
est vu comme quelqu'un qui ne pèse pas
face à l'allemagne face à ses
partenaires européens qui n'a aucune
voix en europe et qui à l'intérieur du
pays aujourd'hui confrontés à de plus en
plus d'obstacle face auquel il est
incapable de réagir tous ces points là
sont notés très précisément évidemment
par la presse européenne une presse qui
s'inspire des gros titres français
l'écotaxe et la rebellion bretonne
encore du grain à moudre pour les
correspondants étrangers de quoi ternir
un peu plus l'image de françois hollande
avec nous donc hervé
qui suit l'elysée pour l' agence
france-presse vos questions à stéphane
le foll et bien stéphane le foll le
président rend compte des records
d'impopularité sous la vème des sondages
catastrophiques que doit-il faire
comment rebondir est-ce qu'il faut un
électrochoc
je me posais une question qui ont fait
consisterait à ce que le ministre de
l'agriculture que je suis puisse
répondre à une question qui dépend
directement d'une décision du président
de la république vous pouvez pas ce que
vous mêmes à moosch nouvelles
innovations qui ferait que les premiers
commentaires qui suivrait serait de
considérer que je me prends pour ce que
je ne suis pas où vous y rajoute riez
sûrement encore un couac donc moi je
suis extrêmement respectueux et des
règles et du gouvernement dans lequel je
travaille pour former un pack le chef de
l'état rappelle moi je serai proche de
lui pour moi je souhaite que dans ce
moment-là extrêmement difficiles je les
dis je l'oraison de le répéter je
rencontre un certain nombre de collègues
on a un seul
nous seule règle c'est la solidarité et
on doit faire face et contrairement à
l'or c'était sympathique de faire passer
les prêts la presse européenne ça c'est
à éviter d'avoir les kills et les
éléments de la presse nationale et ils
veulent la rejoindre j'ai bien compris
donc c'était en fait pour en rajouter il
ya une wii ben moi je considère que dans
ce moment où c'est ce que vous avez
évoqué sert tout le monde crie au loup
est là pour en ajouter à chaque fois que
c'est possible je voyais même que
maintenant la question de la bretagne
c'était encore une question
supplémentaire la question de la
bretagne c'est la question de bretagne
et la question de la bretagne poser
comme elle a été posée sur
l'agroalimentaire et l'agriculture si
c'était que de la responsabilité de
françois hollande on pourrait considérer
qu'à ce moment là il ya une vraie
certains disent que tout ça c'est le
fruit du ras-le-bol fiscale qui
s'annonce de meilleur en comptant par
pierre moscovici c'est un c'est un sujet
qui est en particulier pour la bretagne
une conjonction d'une industrie qui va
mal et qui ferme d'ailleurs avec des
licenciements et la question des quotas
qui vient et qui sert de révélateur de
crise qui cristallise qui cristallise
autour d'elle une mobilisation donc mon
et puis après il ya ceux qui
accompagnent tous en dix ans c'est le
rabot fils cadet qui font de la
politique moi je reste sur les objectifs
et donc je le dis moi ma responsabilité
c'est de dire aujourd'hui face aux
difficultés qui sont les nôtres et bien
il ya une règle absolue qu'il faut
observer et gardées c'est la solidarité
et la solidité parce que si tout le
monde veut dire quoi faire et manon
derrière ça veut dire pas de robin
aubert avant les nîmois jamais j'ai déjà
entendu parler des remaniements ya pas
si longtemps il ya des mois certains qui
d'ailleurs continue demandez à un
remaniement on aurait fait un
remaniement déjà aimé moi on en refera
un autre aujourd'hui donc mois un
remaniement ça d'abord comme sens que si
on se tourne vers l'avenir c'est pas
pour révéler problème de passer ça ça ne
sert à rien un remaniement c'est une
chose qui ouvre une perspective donc moi
aujourd'hui je dis au contraire qu'on
est dans une phase où on doit être
solide et ce alors vous donnez l'image
de sonja liht et de l'autorité stéphane
le foll est ce que certains de vos
collègues en manque moi je ne fais aucun
commentaire sur les coller la bombe est
à moi je suis dit il faut faire entrer
des poids lourds du patrick mennucci qui
dit voilà il faut entraîner voit pas
lourd oui enfin bon quand même si
maintenant et qui n'en met vahidi
martine aubry c'est françois rebsamen
oui mais moi je le jure je vais pas
commenter ce que dit patrick mennucci en
même temps que je le soutiens totalement
événement sur marseille mais je connais
et j'ai entendu je vois bien que tout le
monde peut avoir beaucoup d'imagination
quelques-uns vous faisait référence à ce
qu'elle nous a l'imagination fiscale et
puis maintenant on va voir aussi
l'imagination moi je reste sur la ligne
qu'est la mienne je viens de vous le
dire je suis pas du tout là pour faire
des spéculations il pour évoquer des
questions remaniement et donc a fortiori
des questions personne je suis là pour
rappeler un principe de base quand on
traverse une période de difficultés
comme celle qu'on traverse eh bien on
doit être cohérent solidaire et tenir un
casque quand françois hollande
c'est ce que pense françois hollande il
faudrait lui demander je pense que c'est
ce qu'ils pensent la proche de françois
hollande le voyait régulièrement est-ce
qu'il est affecté la situation dise
si vous apporter un démenti on va
l'enregistrer
est-ce qu'il est affecté
quand même et je records d'impopularité
sur la cinquième c'est inquiétant non
mes choix échappé en dix ans une
pirouette en disant il vaut mieux être
populaire qu impopulaire je suis
connaissant par coeur la seule question
qui est posée c'est que
quand on arrive aux responsabilités d'un
pays qui est en crise
où on regarde les choses en se disant
c'est ma personne où on prend les choses
en se disant c'est mon pays et je sais
que françois hollande ne prend pas les
choses en disant c'est ma personne c'est
mon pays et c'est à mon pays que je dois
cet engagement je suis élu et donc je
sais que c'est comme ça qui prend les
choses il va pas ramener ça toujours à
mon niveau de popularité voilà parce que
voilà il est ce qu'il est maintenant
c'est le pays comment on fait pour que
ce pays
adresse alors il ya une série
d'élections qui viennent devant nous
elle initie pas les européennes etc ça
veut dire à l'issue des élections le
gouvernement le chef de l'état vont
prendre des décisions il y aura un
changement de cap il est appelé par les
français est un homme sur dix quand même
hein donc au lendemain des élections ce
sera le moment
d'abord quels seront les résultats des
élections
pas très bon si on en juge par les
sondages ouais et en même temps si vous
regardez les derniers sondages qui était
sur toulouse qui est sorti je constate
qu'il ya des mauvais sondages puis on a
d'autres des fois qu'ils sont aussi
voilà qui indique que rien en terme de
valve comme on dit ou de deux
catastrophes et se mettre dans cette
situation quand on fait de la politique
c'est accepter la fatalité d'un résultat
négatif donc il faut aussi qu'on soit
capable de porter nous mêmes un peu plus
de confiance et ne pas intégrer tout de
suite les défaites parce que à ce moment
là pour aller mobiliser un électorat qui
s'est déjà pas beaucoup beaucoup
mobilisé et qui perçoit ressent la
difficulté avec ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
alors là eh bien il ya qu'à rajouter ça
et là on est sur deux y arriver au
résultat moi je suis là pour dire au
contraire qu'il faut qu'on se redresse
et qu'on se bouge dans le sens où il
faut aussi qu'on soit à la à l'offensive
qu'on soit aussi capable de revendiquer
ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on est en train de
faire et ce qu'on oublie trop souvent de
rappeler si je dis l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage des jeunes personne
n'a entendu parler on n'en parle pas
assez le président parle de prescrire un
jour
que tout ce qu'on fait ça ne sert à rien
que ça n'a pas d'objectif comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure il reste pas de cap
qu'est ce qu'on a fait comme cas
qu'est-ce qu'on a choisi on a un
problème de déficit qui pose le problème
de l'endettement faut qu'on réduise ses
déficits budgétaires c'est une chance
choix difficiles et pour la gauche en
particulier la compétitivité c'est
deuxième élément la compétitivité majeur
est ce que ces choix sont vraiment
assumé et ce qu'ils ont été expliquées
par le chef de l'état moi je vous dis
qu'il faut les assumer totalement la
compétitivité et on le voit en
particulier par rapport à d'autres pays
ensuite l'emploi et j'entendais un
commentateur je sais pas ou si doux
l'été qui disait il n'ya pas de
politique de gauche
le droite la politique raison d'un
paillis d'el país le soutien à l'emploi
la création d'emplois c'est une
condition de redistribution keynésienne
pour assurer demain une dynamique de
croissance à exit donc cette différence
sociale démocrate et le président
absolue mais le président doit l'assumer
absolument mais toute façon il assume il
avait assumé pendant la primaire est-ce
quelque chose qui sonne et rejoint
l'assumé avec sa majorité qui est quand
même 10 par an bien c'est là que chacun
doit maintenant ces secousses de la
solidarité il faut oui nationalité et on
peut pas se poser tous les gars m'ont
tant que la question vaut à kiel on peut
pas satisfaire tout le temps tout est
question je me rappelle la dévaster t
sur les la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires on avait décidé que dans
un chômage à plus de 10% pourrait pas
mettre 4 milliards d'euros sur les
heures supplémentaires parce que sinon
on mettait de l'argent alors qu'on avait
un problème avec le chômage donc il
fallait me mettre une politique active
contre le chômage de création d'emplois
c'est un choix comment se fait-il
qu'elle était en rediscute de ce qu'on
avait décidé un an avant il faut garder
de la cohérence il faut garder aussi un
peu de sang-froid en prix au sein du
gouvernement mais je ne ferai pas je lis
encore on pas de commentaire au sein des
gones axa taxation de l'ehpad l'impôt
sur les sociétés ça fait quand même
beaucoup de sujets il ya eu tous à
l'écotaxe ces discussions bien parler
les autres sujets alors dans les
épargnes l'afa leonardo toutes ces
affaires c'est ce sont des affaires sur
laquelle il ya eu
sujet atermoiements hésitation trop
cédé sujet c'est vrai que qui sont
arrivés avec des objectifs et des
contraintes
et qui ont fait qu'il y avait eu des
choix un moment et un réajustement
ensuite est-ce que c'est catastrophique
de regarder d'essayer sachant qu'on est
l'accumulation vous
j'ai parfaitement entendu je pense que
tout le monde a parfaitement conscience
que si on peut et qu'on a droit à des
tests ou à des éléments de 2,2 de tests
par rapport à des sujets majeurs on peut
pas le répéter parfaitement entendu
parfaitement conscient donc il faut
aussi qu'on soit capable de se
structurer vos chances pour faire en
sorte que les choix soient discutées
parfaitement évalué avant d'être
présenté quand vous entendez françois
fillion dénoncé la vacance de pouvoir
actuellement que répondez-vous à
l'ancien premier ministre mais je
réponds que si c'était la question de la
vacance je vois pas pourquoi hier soit
par exemple on m'a appelé moi et on a
d'ailleurs mis sur le dos toute la
gestion de l'entreprise ti lyssach ou
puisque c'était moi qui devenait le
responsable pratiquement le pdg de
l'entreprise et si on était en vacance
du pouvoir pourquoi sur la question des
quotas qs il n'y a pas eu aussi de la
part de l'ump les attaques qu'on a
connus qui renie et d'ailleurs les
engagements qu'ils avaient pris et il a
fallu que je dénonce le contrat ecomouv
pour qu'aujourd'hui même au sein de
l'ump il ne soit même pas capable d'être
cohérents entre eux donc il ya un moment
aussi où dans le débat politique est
vrai que chacun ait un peu de hauteur
soit capable aussi de regarder le débat
devant les français et pas simplement
dans un petit jeu politicien on peut ne
pas être d'accord j'ai parfaitement
entendu l'opposition je sais ce qu'elle
dit mais on pourrait éviter de raconter
quelquefois des bêtises parce qu'ensuite
ça laisse à d'autres la capacité de dire
vous voyez tous les mêmes y a qu'à faire
autrement on faire autrement c'est
prendre des risques énormes pour un pays
comme le nôtre en ces mots que françois
hollande a des chances de retrouver son
crédit d'ici la fin du quinquennat aux
cadets france fait mais moi je me met
dans une position qui consiste à dire
les crédits sera retrouvé le jour où on
aura prouvé et montrer que ce qu'on a
fait et qui était difficile a abouti à
des résultats pour un pays comme le
nôtre et ce redressement de ce pays la
fois sous sol son déficit budgétaire les
dépenses publiques l'investissement
l'emploi
c'est là qu'est l'enjeu c'est pour ça
que je disais tout à l'heure françois
hollande ne regarde pas sa cote à lui
c'est celle de la france qu'il faut
qu'on est comme seul enjeu seule
perspective seul élément seule boussole
merci hervé hasquin si michel perin
ternaux de public sénat arrive
maintenant et on va s'interroger bien
sûr vous avez parlé du manque de
solidarité on va s'interroger sur celui
qui apparaît comme peut-être le grand
absent le parti socialiste harlem désir
est la cible de beaucoup de critiques en
ce moment au point que son exfiltration
serait déjà programmée sophie normand
harlem désir premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste en sursis à la tête de
solférino depuis un an le député
européen serait sur la sellette absence
de perspectives manquent de cohésion et
l'esprit collectif trop invisible voire
incompétents
le patron du ps est accusée de ne pas
remplir sa fonction de pôle central de
la majorité et ses dernières
déclarations qui ont pris françois
hollande à contre-pied sur la sphère
leonarda l'ont fragilisé un peu plus
toute insinuation et à mots couverts
plusieurs personnalités du ps verrait
d'un bon oeil son remplacement il
faudrait peut-être avoir un monsieur x
qui correspondent à quoi quelqu'un qui
soit proche du terrain quelqu'un qui se
confronte au suffrage universel
quelqu'un qui ne procèdent pas que d'en
haut mais d'en bas quelqu'un qui soit à
l'écouté des catégories populaires que
nous sommes en train est censé
représenter quelqu'un qui bref soit en
prise avec la société un monsieur x qui
pourrait s'incarner en la personne de
jean christophe cambadélis lui qui n'a
jamais accepté sa défaite à la direction
du parti en 2012 et se veut depuis
toujours très critique à l'égard d'un
même désir parmi les autres noms qui
circulent stéphane le foll actuel
ministre de l'agriculture proche de
françois hollande et guillaume bachelet
l'ancienne plume de laurent fabius
aujourd'hui secrétaire national du ps en
charge de la coordination
mais pas sûr qu'un changement à la tête
de solférino viendrait pour autant
dynamiser un parti dont la structure est
jugé trop bureaucratisé à bout de
souffle on a l'impression que c'est un
jeu interne les gens sont aspirés par
cette vie interne avec ses règles ses
rites ses carrières son langage ses
référents qui se coupent de plus en plus
de la réalité du pays il faut donner
plus de place aux citoyens plus de place
aux intellectuels peut-être plus de
place aussi aux élus les prochaines
échéances électorales avec les
municipales puis les européennes
pourrait être l'occasion d'un renouveau
tant au gouvernement qu'au ps beaucoup
le réclament le voilà à perrine tarneaud
nous ont rejoint pour parler du parti
socialiste mais quand même il ya encore
des questions agricoles un stéphane le
foll sachant que vous allez présenter
dans quelques jours votre loi d'avenir
il sur l'agriculture l'avenir eh bien on
sait qu'elle en a besoin père est mon
vous avez vraiment envie de te prendre
la place dans l'amnésie à la tête du
parti sans
oublier d'évoquer une voie d'avenir
vous avez pas évoqué une réforme de la
politique agricole commune qui on est en
train de terminer un qui a nécessité un
an de négociations donc moi j'ai
suffisamment de travail aujourd'hui pour
ne pas penser rentrer dans le jeu qui
consiste à évoquer les futurs
successeurs darlene deuxième point je
rappelle aussi alors c'est vrai que ça
peut paraître un peu lourd un peu
bureaucratique comme l'a dit jean marie
le guen mais on ne change pas un premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste comme ça
c'est quelque chose qui passe par un
congrès oui il ya une petite procédure
et un premier secrétaire c'est aussi une
majorité dans le parti ça se construit
donc aujourd'hui ils diront va exfiltré
j'entendais le terme le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste issu d'un
congrès non ça se passera pas et ça ne
peut pas se passer comme ça
est-ce que la confiance n'est quand même
pas définitivement rompu entre harlem
désir et le gouvernement font rien faire
aujourd'hui je le disais tout à l'heure
pour remettre en cause ce qui doit être
la solidarité entre nous
je m'adresse
ryan désir moi je vous le dis je ne
serais pas là pour aller dire et faire
des petites phrases je suis là pour
considérer que la période est tellement
difficile que moi ce que je vois que je
fais je les dis cohérence et solidarité
ça pour moi c'est très important donc je
mettrai pas un centime sur ce qui peut
conduire à aller tripatouiller où tout y
est dans tous ces débats je suis je veux
dire volontairement sur ce sujet sans
commentaire c'est christian jacob qui
pensent que vous ne vous intéressez pas
assez à l'agriculture vous ne pensez
qu'à la rue de solférino frileux même
dit que j'étais inexistant puisque j'ai
bien regardé ce qu'il a dit je suis pas
psy pour exister lui le besoin de dire
que
inexistant je vous laisse le soin des
phrases qu'il choisit je pense que j'ai
négocié une réforme de la politique
agricole pas un ange mais en place et
une mode à venir je gémis et des plans
sur la biologie sur l'agroécologie sur
l'apiculture sur tous les sujets qui
sont évoqués je suis au contact je lirai
au contact de vendredi j'écoute je
débats je propose quand on va demain les
vétérinaires descendre dans la rue pour
la première fois depuis 40 ans les
pêcheurs sont mécontents dans les
pêcheurs vous pouvez donner des
responsabilités pas tout le pays
non c'est
donc sur la question des vétérinaires il
ya un sujet derrière qui était
effectivement qui a donné lieu à un
débat entre le ministre de la santé
d'une histoire agriculteurs un vrai
sujet c'est ce qu'on appelle la délivrer
aussi des antilles mais parce qu'il ya
la question de l'antibiorésistance c'est
pas un petit sujet c'est à dire le fait
que aujourd'hui des résistances aux
antibiotiques qui font qui fait que le
risque c'est que demain les ans il me
dit que puisque plus soignée donc il
faut qu'on soit vigilant dans la
distribution et la délivrance des
antibiotiques doc avait une proposition
que nous avions fait qu avait été
contestée discutée par la santé qui
consistait à dire on ne peut pas
associer des faut découper ce qui est la
prescription d'antibiotiques et de
l'acte vétérinaire
aujourd'hui à la fois prescrire des
antibiotiques et les délits va aussi
voilà donc là qu'on est revenu sur cette
ligne et on va travailler et ce avec le
ministère de la santé pour se donner un
cadre avec les vétérinaires parce que
l'objectif qu'on doit poursuivre c'est
ce qu'on a fait c'est ce qui a été fait
depuis cinq ans c'est à dire une baisse
de près de 40% du recours aux
antibiotiques et surtout ce qu'on
appelle aux antibiotiques critiques
c'est à dire ceux qui peuvent être
utilisés pour les hommes et donc il faut
qu'on soit à l'étranger les jt vénère
sont d'accord donc on a discuté là
encore on avait fait une proposition
elle a été discutée que ministère de la
santé parce que c'est un sujet de santé
publique et marisol touraine a eu raison
aussi de défendre un point de vue
maintenant on a vu ensemble avec marisol
touraine les vétérinaires c'était hier
je crois ils ont souhaité maintenir la
manifestation
et ils le savent je vous le dis on a
trouvé un accord ensemble à bon chat bon
oui mais sur des films mais vous avez
quand même un accord oui
mais on ne pouvait pas avec un péché de
bonheur puisqu'il de souhaiter l'ex du
politique du jour le mariage ou en tout
cas l'alliance entre françois bayrou et
jean-louis borloo donc françois bayrou
qui repart vers la droite sans regret de
votre part
moi je pense que dans les moments qu'on
vit
il faut des paroles politiques qui
soient aussi là pour apaiser les
tensions donc je suive
oui justement donc je ne suis pas là
pour les critiquer c'est un choix qu'ils
ont fait ils sont libres de faire ce
choix je pense simplement ce que
j'espère j'espère
ce que j'espère c'est qu'ils ne tombent
pas dans la caricature qui est celle qui
est donnée aujourd'hui par l'ump si
c'est pour faire la même chose là c'est
vrai que ça sera parfaitement
contestable mais si c'est pour faire
autre chose un bon vent au mariage
j'attends de voir
c'est parce que aujourd'hui vous nous
donniez l'expression de christian jacob
qui traite le ministre de l'agriculture
inexistant c'est parfait en terme de
débats politiques de hauteur de vue on
est vraiment au bon niveau je disais
quand j'ai vu comment l'opposition et du
mp s'est comporté sur cette question de
l'écotaxe alors que eux mêmes le savez
c'est eux qu'il avait décidé et que ils
se sont permis de dire il faut tout
arrêter et faut tout c'est le sait le
matraquage fiscal même je le répète
madame quand tu t'ouvres 16 9 mais oui
je pense que j'attends plus de
responsables il y avait plus d'auteurs
dans un moment où c'est la france je le
répète c'est pas le sujet de du ministre
de l'agriculture c'est pas le sujet
uniquement du gouvernement ces sujets
d'un pays alors au prince grand pays que
dans l'opposition lui des modems
représente une belle alternative pour
j'ai dit simplement je ne savais pas ce
qui allait se passer si c'est pour faire
la même chose ça sera parfaitement
contestable après qu'est ce qu'ils
feront ensemble je regarde des photos je
ne sais pas entrer dans leur charte il
n'y aura pas d'alliance avec le parti
socialiste
belhout sur wii mais moi j'ai constaté
que certains membres du modem
aujourd'hui ont déjà fait un choix
différent
s'est pas vu jouer
mais pas vraiment répondu à la question
c'est quand même un échec pour le parti
socialiste on rappelle que françois
bayrou a voté un ange il a tendu la main
vous n'avez pas saisi regrettez vous est
ce que vous le regrettez on entend on a
vu jean marie le guen vermaas temps d'un
reportage à propos de de cette situation
il dit que le ps est victime de son
sectarisme tu crois pas c'est qu'on a
aussi
une histoire
cette gauche française a une histoire et
on peut dire que quelquefois heine elle
ne nous aide pas la gauche de la gauche
quelquefois par des prises de positions
qu'on connaît bien mais donc c'est pas
si facile que ça à jeter comme ça un
argument consiste à y entrer secteur
c'est aussi plus compliqué même pour
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'est ce que
veut exactement françois bayroux par
rapport aux objectifs moi j'ai pas de
deux sujets le choix qu'il avait fait à
l'époque était parfaitement motivé il
l'avait expliqué et il était aussi un
choix pas stratégique à l'époque c'était
sur une élection en même temps je
considère après je ne sais pas ce qui va
se passer je considère qu'on ne faut pas
qu'on soit là pour rajouter du débat
politicien et du débat de petites
petites discussions alors je ne maîtrise
pas quelle est la charte quel est le
mariage et qui est la convention d'achat
histoire à suivre martine aubry elle
montre les dents face au groupe pinault
qui veut vendre la redoute assez le
retourne martin la combattante je pense
que martin c'est pas un retour de la
combattante l'a toujours été passées
pour pour vous le lirez tant que je peux
aussi dire que martin n'a jamais
abandonné son caractère ça je suis sûr
de ça et donc elle est aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet mobilisés pour défendre aussi
les emplois et elle fait exactement ce
que nous faisons moi je le dis aux
salariés de tilly sakho je n'ai jamais
lâché la perspective qui était la mienne
d'avoir un pôle export qui
c'est en bretagne et ça sera ça
l'objectif et j'espère que en ayant mis
un certain nombre de choses sur la table
on arrivera à passer cette étape
difficile à la bretagne ne dit pas ce
cas est connue la lorraine avec la
sidérurgie ce que vous dites je pense
que c'est différent la sidérurgie
c'était une industrie est un minerai
aujourd'hui la question agricole c'est
la production agricole sur lequel il
faut qu'on soit aussi en capacité
d'innover c'est ce que je ferai vendredi
et en même temps une industrie
agroalimentaire qui là pour transformer
des lignes rouges à l'instant où nous
parlons aux menaces de nouvelles actions
c'est l'éco taxe n'est pas purement et
simplement supprimée mais un choc
lorsqu'il ya aussi dans ce débat je
connais bien et en particulier le leader
qui s'appelle merrett je connais bien et
d'ailleurs je voudrais juste rappeler
cette petite histoire sur les bonnets
rouges dans l'histoire de la bretagne
que je connais un peu en 775 suite au
papier timbré cette histoire sa marque
cette révolte des bonnets rouges la fin
du cycle de prospérité le plus long que
comme la bretagne est elle est entré
après dans un cycle de déclin jusqu'à la
seconde guerre mondiale jusqu'à là au
milieu du xxème siècle donc moi je ne
suis pas du tout dans cet esprit je
pense que la beauté fin et rebondir et
vite une question sur les 100 clés sur
les centres équestres inquiet de la
hausse de la tva qui va passer de 7 à 20
% qui va les frapper à ras cadets 1er
janvier ils vous demandent de revenir en
arrière vous aller les écouter mais moi
j'étais celui là encore c'est passé
inaperçu c'est normal j'étais celui qui
au gouvernement et avec l'appui du
premier ministre est considéré que sur
la question de la tva qui était imposé
partout en europe et par la commission
européenne sur la filière équine il
fallait protéger les centres équestres
pendant un an je le dis j'ai et le
premier ministre m'avait dit je te suis
je te fais confiance j'ai bataillé pour
essayer de trouver une solution la
commission vient de rendre son avis et
elle dit non elle dit non ya pas elle
dit la tva s'applique au niveau de la
filière équine à toute la filière est au
centre de la filière seraient menacés
selon la fédération oui mais j'ai bien
entendu donc il faut qu'on regarde
maintenant et ça c'est une discussion
que je vais avoir
que le recours on est déjà sûr
manquements sur mon coin et je les fais
rko il ya un an j'ai fait recours et
quand j'ai été voir le premier ni génie
je veux il faut qu'on tendre tout pour
sauver les centres équestres depuis un
an d'ailleurs la tva c'est appliquer
tous les autres sauf au centre équestre
et maintenant l'europe a dit non saint
lô avait manqué voilà donc il faut qu'on
soit devant met les bâtons dans les
roues la vaisselle ménage
ce que j'ai fait une et man et
sincèrement je pas là pour raconter des
histoires je suis là pour vous dire ce
que j'ai fait et après vous dire aussi
que et bien après cette période j'ai pas
pu obtenir le résultat que je souhaitais
mais chut je vais vous lire d'accord
serait ridicule de vous dire le
contraire il ya un livre qui raconte
quand il en était le premier secrétaire
du ps il avait ses fans le foll derrière
lui jean-françois disais oui stefano
phone passé derrière pour dire bah il
t'a dit oui mais en fait c'est le monde
estimant qu aujourd'hui quelqu'un pour
clarifier on a lu ça dans un article
récent à du figaro bon bon c'est ça
c'est ça votre corps votre duo de se
faire et nos os c'était plus compliqué
que ça avant un sommet mais pas plus
compliqué que ça
et oui il faut une fois quelqu'un il
faut réorganiser l'elysée par exemple
c'est ce qu'on dit aussi aujourd'hui
l'événement
je vous voulez m'emmener non mènerait
pas sur ce terrain là je vous ai dit ce
que je pensais
et puis je ferai moi là je suis tout
pour idée je pense qu'il faut
aujourd'hui tenir et soon
voilà la règle c'est toujours très
complexe et la relation entre deux
hommes merci par une merci monsieur le
ministre la semaine prochaine notre
invité sera jean pierre raffarin bonsoir
et à très vite